you
and what I asked you guys to questions
all of you and just briefly on Mondays
class they showed in the in the search
of unknown I think you guys have seen at
the distribution of returns and I
mentioned earlier that that wasn't my
experience as an investor if you just
answered go down the line and answer two
questions one what percent of the search
funds you invest in do you think get a
deal what percent of those deals do you
do and what percent of those deals work
out and I'll start with myself my own
experience is about three-quarters of
the people who start a search fund to
find a deal it's been down a little bit
the last two years about three-quarters
of those fields I do and about 90 plus
percent of them ever have a reasonable
return of capital so that was that's my
own experience Bob
terms of percentages probably a half a
dozen deals searches over the last she's
23 years or so never never concluded
never found a company you know I bet
I've turned down at 25 percent maybe
more in terms of the deal we we've
conclusively demonstrated that we know
how to kill companies done that a couple
different times Jim and I did one
together but most yeah I mean in general
they all produce decent returns I mean I
I know there's a lot of focus on IRR is
I just you know if I start out with this
and I end up with this and this one's
bigger I usually figure it's a good deal
and most of them
seventy-five percent 75 percent and 75
percent I'd say we're probably 80% we
probably only invest in half the deals
that are brought to us and and there are
all sorts of reasons that we we turn
them down and then probably 80% 80% of
works out well so that's a pretty
different distribution than a search
fund note and you probably have 65% of
the data points or 50% of the data
points represented in this room so there
must be something that is pushing people
to look to the left so yeah and which of
the three deals did you guys support I
didn't support any of them I would what
I would have told the the the searcher
is is the I think these are three
special you know true believer
especially consumer market deals if they
wanted to do the Green was the
fertilizer or toys I could put them up
put them in touch with people who knew
something about that because I don't
know anything about consumer products
per se I could be talked into the
veterinary business and I thought it had
critical due diligence questions that
you really could answer and the other
two quite other two businesses you
couldn't so I wouldn't have I would have
said shut it down you know you play the
game well but sorry
I love the toy business I just I think
this is a great company it's not it's
really not toys it's nostalgia products
for parents and grandparents to buy give
it to the kid the kid plays with it once
or twice and it's it's over by the
Christmas tree and they feel good about
having bought it it's got a premium
price the manufacturing process can't be
that complicated you can outsource it
the there's little or no IP content here
you all you really have to and and and
the sales force is only paid in cash
after they sell the product probably
after they collect the money
so it's a it's a legal classic pyramid
structure like Amway or any other
company you've heard about he was an
insurance sales and I can I can just see
I mean I don't think that Marks and
Spencer at Marks & Spencer Marx and Turk
should should try to manage the sales
force I think they should go conduct a
methodical search with a paid HUD
headhunter and find somebody who's
probably older and has done this and
been very successful in some successful
marketing structure similar to this I
think that you can the IRR is I think
they're under estimating the potential
this business I just think that with
with a little help from somebody who who
an investor perhaps that's that's sees
this thing there's a more attractive
opportunity they can get the I our hours
up into the range where investors will
get excited very simple company to
operate I would start with just thinking
about the seller and from in oral
experience the seller is absolutely
critical
less integral to the business so not
involved or terribly much in the
customer relationships not involved in
critical functions one of the big
problems we saw with them right so at
the toy business was she runs product
development product development you toy
companies are all about product
development so if she goes AWOL on you
you're toast
inch and that they not be terribly in
there they're gonna be involved with the
people but you don't want the people to
be loyal to them you want them to be
gloy to the company and like second that
the seller be available third that the
seller be willing to leave capital at
risk for that the seller have a really
good reason for selling fifth that they
have reasonable expectations and it
wasn't in 12 with the expectations of
either of the first two companies that
fertilizer business or the toward joint
company they both seemed like they were
starting out fairly high and they were
people I guess the last thing was they
were a little more emotional than or
creative than rational and I think
having a seller it is an incredibly
complex process to buy a company and
gonna have to talk through a lot of
issues and if you have people who have
outsized expectations at the beginning
that's a that's a reason and and may not
reason things terribly clearly that's a
warning sign so at the end of the day we
I came down on american veterinary like
industry growth six to nine percent
relatively recession-proof
fragmented industry in terms of the
company good reputation for service and
low turnover and the personnel that's a
always a big issue i suspect it's at a
point of inflection in terms of the
corporate staff they have a big
corporate team and if you do succeed in
driving revenues after that you may find
that the operating leverage is very high
I like the cellar situation was a guy in
his 60s it didn't sound like you was
gonna be leaving anywhere we think
someone who's going to disappear to the
day after the sale is is a is fatal to
us seller the relative growth avenues
adding services I think jju focused on
that sort of expanding the service
offering visit declines we were worried
about or I was worried about but I
concluded that if the industry is
growing you're probably that's probably
more an execution issue than it is an
industry issue and in something that
should be solvable financial systems was
a real concern but it may also be an
opportunity you have to figure out well
you can get them in place once you
understand how the different 15
locations are doing you may find that
one's doing something really well that
you can roll out to the other location
and so I those are big red flags but
things that we could probably get
through and diligence I thought the
problems I saw with the other businesses
much harder to address through due
diligence these ones were things that
you could ultimately understand through
your diligence and figure out whether
you could deal with the risks or nothing
I think it's less important which
companies the three of these investors
wanted to back and more insight
now Jim had brought me the toy deal by
God I will listen because that
enthusiasm that enthusiasm and passion
and thoughtfulness about it really
struck me I probably would have turned
them down in the end but it would
definitely have gotten my attention
because he thought it through onto
something and that's the side stuff but
it's obviously also hinted and
fertilized potential liability exposure
and if I'm running my search when I
can't afford some Sacher and in terms of
potential liability exposure how what I
meant to ask you earlier how to find a
great lawyer and and also how do you go
about something that's so hard to
quantify well the so the the fertilizer
business I worried a little bit about
the things you brought up I I felt like
that on many dimensions that's a very
poor fit the business of Barratt very
poor fit with for an inexperienced
search fund entrepreneur or
entrepreneurial team you've got the the
the the there is some legal risk when
you when you hear that hunter well
hunter scares me when I hate when I hear
that he doesn't like to see the bosses
coming around his shop his lab but more
importantly to scale this company you've
got to triple the infrastructure you've
got to go from
two three labs from one six plants from
two six warehouses from two and you got
two years to do that and it's a tall
order for people who have never run a
company before so I would but it really
finding a lorry
that's pretty it's pretty easy to do I
mean you through your network and so
forth
but one of the issues here this is
really a startup company that's a few
years old and one of the big mysteries
of startups especially if you get early
traction with revenue you just can't
tell if that's low-hanging fruit or if
that's really indicative of the
marketplace and one of the things that
struck me about this I mean you know
organic fertilizers have been around for
years and the people that buy them are
willing to pay the price the premium are
really true believers it's hard to
figure out yet if they're indicative of
the of a big true believer market and
that was the thing that really turned me
and plus you know going back to what I
said you know so if there's somebody in
the company who you're critically
dependent upon this guy the chemist or
whatever he is and he can't be managed
man here you're toast if you
I'll throw in my two cents which is then
a good lawyer is really hard to find and
I don't mean that in a pejorative sense
I think especially a great lawyer is
very hard to find but within your
investor group that's just a perfect in
the second party question about about
product liability I believe that there
are certain risks and that looks scary
on the front end but our insurable and I
think that's that feels to me like an
insurable risk and II I just want to
follow up on Jo's question earlier
they're really really hard and the time
to do a rollup is when you're clearly at
the point where you're running the
company and it's not running you and it
takes you a couple of years to get to
that point and you've got a culture in a
system and a methodology into which
you're merging something so that the new
companies that you're buying are not
going to be changing the the culture and
the style of your company but even with
that there are so many things to
consider in roll-ups that if I'm not
real enthusiastic about going into a
company where the roll-up strategy is
corner this is sort of pivotal to its
long-term success it's my own my own
personal view yeah I I think you know in
the in the and the american veterinary
deal you're going to be you're going to
have thirteen and a half million dollars
tied up in a bunch of stores that don't
have any organic sales growth and so the
the investment thesis is to go out and
buy more stores that don't have any
organic sales growth if you can't get
these stores to grow that you got i
don't see how you're going to make a
return on this investment by putting
more money to work in non growing stores
i also think that you're going to
pay more for the stores you buy then it
would cost to open them by a huge margin
but you are getting some even top but
it's not growing I think I'd probably
look at opening new stores and see if I
could make some money if I if you made
me do that deal I would look at opening
my own new stores they're real good
that's a classic make by decision if
it's an industry that has been around a
long time and it's still fresh better
know why the one other thing about
roll-ups and I spend a fair amount of
time doing them with Brentwood
associates and and one of our most
successful investments is a rollout but
one of the real issues actually Golf
Courses trade magazines number of course
and right now we've got a company that's
in methadone clinics but one of the real
issues is the management complexity
because if you and and it's probably one
of the bigger negatives to me about
American vet but I think it's overcoming
it but you generally you have 15
locations they're probably the top paid
person who's your P&L manager is making
$50,000 they that doesn't have a lot of
education doesn't have real management
experience that they've kind of grown up
through the ranks and that person is
that's your front line that's your front
line piano manager we had this problem
in spades in the golf course business
and you can set up all sorts of fancy
incentive structures that they they
don't we gave them all equity they
didn't understand what equity meant
until the day they cashed the check and
and it was I mean it worked out
splendidly but not it was almost despite
that issue not because of it it's tough
I can see a path miss Pina 30 times
dealing you can see that how contracted
that but doesn't even ever consider or I
probably turn it down just because it's
a specialty consumer deal I just don't
know I mean every time I've done
something like that I've lost money
which tells you that tells tilt would
tell you and me that you know I don't
know anything about it and I can't bring
anything to the table besides money
I could probably introduce you to some
people who could so if you had a group
of as in the toy case you know if you
had a group of investors who really
understood that business and can figure
out how to help you be successful that's
what you want but I just wouldn't be
that person we have a much shorter time
with I grow her high really high risk
with a high reward situations we're not
venture capitalists were buyout guys and
and much more focused on you know get a
good business that you could you think
you have high confidence you're gonna
make some money on and then hopefully
the way you make a lot of money on it is
by getting it into an adjacent industry
that really where you can get that
growth but with relatively low risk
based on my experience when you talk to
someone or you know you say well you
shouldn't say like most of them will say
you know yeah at the right price you
know of course but like what's the
strategy or in your experience what's
been the most successful strategy like
like determining you know who actually
is realistic I'm like getting down to it
because a lot of times it seems like you
know they're willing to have a
conversation you can spin your wheels
for a while in that case what are the
tactics that you have seen that have
worked the best take a step so so just
to be clear I don't make that many phone
calls and every one of them that I make
gets answered about a person that I want
to talk to that is that is my whole
purpose in life when I'm searching
because - I've done it I've knocked on
doors door to door selling life
insurance and I hated it I've made a
hundred calls a day and I hated it and
so I've just I want to have these warm
introductions where they hey so you know
Joe Schmoe and we talk about their
fishing trips and all that kind of stuff
so it's a much more pleasant search but
there's a lot of time between those
calls so you got to do something so you
might as well look at opportunistic deal
flow coming in and over over the transom
qualifying sellers is not as an art it's
not a science and there are all kinds of
things that you can look at I don't have
a laundry list of you know if you do
these 10 things you're home free I mean
first of all if the sellers old it's
better than if they're young if they got
kids who ought nothing to do with the
business it's better than if they have a
son or a daughter who's already in the
business if you can get the wife or the
spouse to know how much money is
involved and they think about spending
it that's good if if the seller is will
if the seller is willing to is willing
to immediately introduce you to his
employees as you know the potential new
owner
that comes down longer and if they're
willing to let you talk to their
customers all of those things are kind
of signs that they're that they're
serious if the amount of money involved
if you know enough about their personal
financial circumstances to suggest that
the amount of money involved is
something they really can live with you
know you're gonna run a lot across a lot
of businesses a ten million dollar
business the entrepreneur has taken a
couple of million dollars out of here
and he's gonna get eight million dollars
in cash but that ain't gonna work in no
way you can invest eight million dollars
after taxes and make two million dollars
a year I mean so there's a whole bunch
of things like that you sort of need to
get your arms around when it comes to
figuring out if the person who's going
to sell is real really critical because
in a search fund your biggest enemy is
time that you have to do your search and
it is easy to burn nine months on a deal
which is happy chunkier search fun I
mean in the end the guy was never gonna
sell or was never gonna sell under terms
that were reasonable to you and it's
funny you got a chuckle when he said get
the people is to spend their money but
when I bought my first company a guy
that was an advisor to me who was very
it was a very very big deal savvy and he
ended up being our attorney it wasn't an
investor and he said the guy the sellers
name was George's he said get George and
Karla his wife to start spending the
money in their head and
and I did and I asked him so what are
you gonna do afterwards and they talked
about buying this ranch and arrows in
and what happiness is I could see that
they had moved on that he was actually
in a different place and he wanted to
get to that place mentally and that
convinced me that in fact it was a
cellar just exit one quick point and
that is you know it's been years since
I've seen this survey but typically when
you ask somebody who are you they answer
by giving you their title and the
company they work for which is the wrong
answer in most sellers are intimately
identified with their company and so
you're trying to figure out just what
David said that they're willing to
separate and we've seen I've seen I can
think of three deals that busted at the
very end because the seller just
couldn't in the end
imagine themselves not running that
company and that's what you got to
figure out as quickly as you possibly
can so you know we should have just
ignored it because he might but we
should have really had plan B
if you don't leave that I'd go see
because I don't make many calls i I can
afford to go see everybody that I get in
contact with if I don't leave that first
meeting with a pledge from him to send
me as financials and him he or she
haven't given me some broad range of
what their EBIT dye is and the number of
employees and that kind of stuff if not
hand me the financials on the way out
the door then I really don't take that
much further because there's really not
anything to discuss I know so many
searchers that have spent nine months
courting sellers who never get to first
base with them
and how do you think about the
perspective the commitment you're making
and I had that conversation with the
searcher waking the best of them
initially because it's obviously very
challenging for the
searcher to have a company and have
attempted syllables best years who for
whatever reason decided not to
participate the assessment surgery
perspective and
a seller's perspective Brad way around
saying I have these people who will give
me money in the future what role we play
in the selling in
the acquisition process actually we have
a couple of times been asked to go out
one time we were asked to go out and
visit with a seller a couple of number
of times talked with a seller to give
them comfort that we were serious we we
never say we're going to back the person
in whatever the deal is that would be
nonsense we don't know what the deal
with the transaction the company etc
what of the numbers I think we turn down
the most deals that are presented to us
it isn't that we just say no goodbye we
have usually along the way tried to say
you know you're here are our issues if
you can address these and deplore
diligence and mitigate the risks we're
gonna take a hard walk but so we're
trying to give the searcher a lot of
questions know what is it that would
make it a good deal or a bad deal and
Toria so that they're not usually really
is someone surprised by what our
response we've telegraphed it along the
way by the questions and if they can
answer them we're all ears if they can't
it's great we've got maintained good
relationship for their investors and
keep them apprised all the way along
don't surprise them at the end of the
deal but in the real world today you're
gonna have a gap in a the banks aren't
where they used to be so you know you've
got a problem there for all kinds of
reasons I mean 20 years ago I could say
with absolute confidence any deal I was
involved and you can get it done with
the investors around the table there was
enough debt financing available markets
were a lot different today that's not
true
so I think you just it's a matter of
making having good communications with
your investors I talked to sellers on a
regular basis on this issue to convince
them that you know this particular
option or has a very smart group of
investors who know how to get these
things done and if the due diligence
proceeds properly as you just mentioned
you know that will be there
he hires required nobody just never
thought this person was well if that
hire is going to be made right away in
the calculation of the EBIT Dom multiple
I like to see that person's salary in
the EBIT da that calculates the multiple
and then if it's if it's a small company
and that takes even da from a million
down to seven hundred and fifty thousand
dollars and we're now paying fourteen
times even I don't like that if it
really if it's if it's you know two
million dollars and it takes it down ten
percent then I that looks different
cosmetically and substantively well that
might be so you okay
if on the other hand this isn't one of
about eight things that have to get done
in order for this deal to work out then
I would be less likely to do it so I
would I would just put it in the basket
of operational risk that you're taking
or executing look and say the other
thing is it just depends what the what
the position is if you're trying to hire
a CFO that's gonna we would be a lot
more sympathetic to that than if you're
trying to hire someone to replace the
product development person at the toy
company that we would worry a lot about
it just depends how mission the central
it
we're smart either that or we do a great
job of culling out the ones that are
least likely to succeed and work out
there those are two different things
that you really just never know what
you've invested in is gonna work out
which are gonna be the the winner and so
but it's pretty easy to spot the dogs
why don't we take these in two chunks
let's talk first about the ability if
there is an ability to spot a successful
searcher when they're raising their
search and I'll begin with I'm sort of
in Jim's camp I think it's literally
hard anymore to identify after a meeting
or to whether someone's gonna be
successful but there are a half a dozen
questions that I asked and I bet the
panelists have their own half a dozen
questions that allow me to weed out some
some obvious problems Bob just on the
issue of the search fund yeah it's it's
it's it's one of the mysteries and
thrills of doing this because I mean I
I'm not going to name names but I can
think of some people who are you know if
I invest I've concluded I've concluded
that this person is capable of doing
this but you know the moon shots have
been surprises in fact a very well-known
professor in the business school when I
now who used to give me some detailed
evaluations of students now would say to
me when I call him and say of course you
know I no longer make predictions and
it's just because it's really hard and
so you try and make the best judgments
you can
Stanly the data that's available and and
then then then you put work in with the
with the entrepreneur to help them be
successful search button
yeah tip to me the critical thing is
does a person do I think this is someone
who really wants to run a small business
actually get in and wrap their arms
around that and who's gonna like
managing people of all different
backgrounds so for me it's much more a-
screen if they if i don't see that or if
i sense anything that tells me this guys
would be much happier working for
Goldman than running a business that's a
huge red flag and we'll walk away guys
out of the military or girls out of
military are actually a pretty good sign
for us a good favorable sign because
they have made decisions they've led
people they've managed people they've
got people blue collar white collar
everything they they deal with it and
that's a big plus to us so well I know
that the that the vast majority of
companies in the 22 search funds that
I've been in that bought companies and
have exited the they had really good
corporate governance they had a one or
two strong directors on their boards
that took them to task at every meeting
on the important issues and made sure
that in the early years they focused on
important things that's one common
thread
there's luck plays a role they that they
ended up choosing good industries so
you're talking about of the ones that
worked out that I invested in and worked
out yeah so not the ones that I avoided
because I called them out
industries and you said you said which
of those industries just don't make
sense and you pulled them out I think
you would immediately to the right
absolutely
I don't feeling it most of that is
explained by industry the second piece
which is a cousin of that is explained
by opportunistic search versus an
industry search and I think if you just
change those two variables you have a
very different outcome research funds I
want to just have a couple of closing
remarks and first of all we've got great
we had a great opportunity here to have
these three people
I don't always clap - all right in the
middle of the rest of my life I walk in
a dark wood where the true way was
wholly lost from Midway upon the journey
of our life I found myself within a dark
for the straightforward pathway on me a
hard thing it is to say but with the
sport savage rough concern which in the
very thought renews the peer so bitter
it is death is a little more but of the
good to treat which I dare found speak
will I of the other things I saw there I
cannot well repeat ah there I entered so
full I was a slumber at the moment in
which I had abandoned in the true way
but after I had reached a mountain split
at that point were the valley terminated
which had with consternation pierced my
heart a word I looked and I beheld his
shoulders best and already with that
planet's rays which leadeth others right
by every road there is a temptation I
think in human existence to base your
life on contingency to only take that
first greatest step when all the
conditions are perfect when your list of
criteria have been fully met and the
same can be applied for your personal
criteria
I'll step into the ring after my student
once I have operational experience when
the market improves after I get the down
payment on my house my kids get in
school after I graduate it says if we
could complete if we could completely
control the climate of our existence get
the temperature just right only when we
have a full sense of freedom then I'll
take that courageous step but I don't
think that completely that complete
control over your life and the variables
in your life ever really exist in the
real world so in the middle of the rest
of my life I walk in a dark wood where
the true way was totally lost